Apple watch Ultra 2 what are going to be
the changes when is it going to come out
and what will be the price tag well we
have some new rumors along with some
other recent ones that we are going to
cover and I'll let you know what I am
personally very interested in as far as
upgrades that will make a lot of people
want to buy one the latest leak that we
have here is from the Chinese website
weibo stating that the new Apple watch
Ultra will be lighter than the current
one now a lot of people made a big fuss
about the size and weight of the Apple
watch Ultra and of course it is way
heavier than the series 8 Apple watch
and of course the SE and maybe even
because of that Apple released only soft
lightweight and nylon bands for it
instead of a nice titanium band like the
one that I have on that many of you guys
comment and asked me what it is well
this thing is only about 35 bucks I
bought it on Amazon I'll link it below
and I absolutely love it and maybe the
reason Apple did not release one of
these like they have one for the series
8 is just because it would add a lot
more weight now the user that released
this is setsuna digital and they are the
ones that put out the info on the yellow
iPhone 14 so they have been accurate in
the past now how would Apple make this
watch lighter well we have another rumor
This Time by Ming Chi kuo who is
extremely accurate saying the apple is
going to start 3D printing parts for the
ultra now being an extremely rugged
watch that had me kind of thinking very
skeptical 3D printing is not as strong
as cncing but looking further this is
going to be titanium 3D printing and the
components could include the digital
Crown the side button and the action
button these are currently all done
using CNC Machining takes a lot of time
to do that and those those are really
the only parts of that move on here so
quo stated that the changes could
improve the production time and reduce
the costs and maybe because of that that
can also lower the weight because they
can make it a little bit more efficient
and in our previous video a while ago
Vadim showed off a new laser based crown
that could be used for much more
accurate adjustment when you're spinning
the dial because right now if you spin
it really fast well it can kind of lag
behind and if Apple does this code
believes that's going to push the whole
industry forward just like when Apple
adopted CNC parts and I think that would
be really cool now personally I don't
really care about the weight that much I
absolutely love the ultra I care more so
about the thickness and that would be
sweet to see it be slightly thinner and
that could happen in a couple ways one
of Apple's biggest focuses on the ultra
is the battery life and they want to
maintain that really killer battery life
but we're going to have some other
updates that will help now what team
also recently made an iPhone 15 video on
brand new tech the apple is implementing
and if you haven't seen that video make
sure to watch it after they have this
new winding technology for Batteries
instead of stacking that is much more
efficient and it allows you to either
have much more battery capacity like we
saw the rumors for the iPhone 15s or if
you want to hit a certain point you can
make the battery smaller and take up
less room and that could help out as
well and another thing that will
drastically help is a brand new chip and
we should see the S9 chip in the ultra 2
and the Apple Watch series 9. now that
seems like a given but if you didn't yet
know the chip that is inside of this
Apple watch Ultra is actually a thousand
four hundred and 14 days old that is
because Apple kept renaming their Apple
watch chips while they're practically
the same going all the way back to the
S6 chip so the S7 and the S8 in here
they are identical and they are based on
a seven nanometer design which is not
bad but the new S9 Chip is going to be
based on five nanometer this is going to
be based off of the a15 processor so
it's going to have a much better design
that not only will improve performance
but it also will affect battery life now
the ultra right now is amazing I never
have any glitches stutters none of that
whatsoever so I don't care about the
performance side but the battery life
will be great and with that said I can
use the thing for three days without any
issues and it is wonderful so if they
get a lot of battery and Chip
improvements they could make it a little
thinner because right now I don't like
doing sleep tracking with it it because
it is so bulky and uncomfortable
compared to the regular Apple watches
now with that the other thing that we've
talked about is a smaller Apple watch
Ultra the current 49 millimeter one is
awesome but for a lot of people it is
just way too big now I actually ordered
two of these when they came out one for
myself and one for my wife and it just
looked comical on her hands so she did
not keep it she got a series eight
instead and even for me it took a while
to get used to it now nine to five Mac
actually ran a pole in a huge 61.53
percent said that they really like the
ultra it is just too big and if they
made a smaller version they would buy it
of course it'd be smaller a little bit
thinner but it would be able to maintain
that great battery life because of the
previous improvements that we talked
about now with that said I actually want
to buy my kid and maybe kids and Apple
watch Ultra if they make a smaller
version because currently they are using
the SE with cellular and we showed you
guys a video about how to set it up and
it's great to be able to pay not a lot
each month be able to text them know
where they're at it has been an amazing
tool but because they're running mostly
on cellular not linked to an iPhone they
die so quickly in a smaller Ultra would
be amazing for that it's an expensive
watch yes and we'll talk about price but
it would be awesome for a lot of people
I think Apple would be dumb if they do
not make a smaller Ultra happen let me
know your thoughts down below now the
next thing they absolutely do is to sell
a titanium band with the Apple watch
Ultra it's a major oversight I bought
this one right here it's a very cheap
one and Nomad made this excellent
perfectly matched band that vadima's
wearing right now it's 300 bucks it's
very expensive and it was sold out for
like seven or eight months and if they
can get the weight down or they just
want to sell it I think a lot of people
would spring for that extra because it
takes it from just a sporty watch to
something that looks a lot more premium
now we also had some leaks about them
giving it a 10 larger display uh rumor
to launch next year and that is crazy
because nobody would say that they need
a bigger display but I think if they
make the bezel thinner that was where
that would come from and along with that
we had a lot of info on Apple working on
a micro LED display but that was pushed
to the second half of
2025. now that display would not only be
larger but it would actually get
brighter and save battery at the same
time now if you're thinking about
waiting for that well we also got an
update where instead of 2024 now it's
going to be pushed to
2025 and maybe even
2026 and that sounds like a more big
redesign so I would say if you you've
been wanting to pick up one of these do
not wait for
um a micro LED display not mini LED now
as far as the release date it's going to
be coming out at the same time as the
iPhone 15 and 15 Pro that's when Apple
always updates these
um and I think that's going to be great
just a couple months away so don't buy
one right now because we could have a
few different changes there's a
potential that could have a change in
price I know some people don't think
that Apple changes prices but my
stainless steel gold one that I bought
for 850 a year or two later they
actually dropped the price down by 50
bucks and then of course if they do
release a smaller model instead of this
huge one well in that case smaller model
is going to be 100 less expensive and it
would fit on a lot more people's wrists
even if you're somebody like me which
usually would buy a larger standard
design Apple watch well the ultra is in
the smaller version would still look
absolutely perfect and it would save you
some money you guys let me know if
you're excited for the new Apple watch
Ultra 2 and if you would end up buying
one click that Circle above and check
out the two great videos that I
mentioned in this video they're both
awesome right over there and I will see
you in the next one
foreign